the streets of harkiev have been
abandoned by the majority of those who
live here
half a million have fled this city
their prized possessions in a bag
and their cars discarded at the station
those who remain hide in the shadows in
the dark or the deep underground
more than a dozen metro stations have
been turned into shelters
these battered looking train carriages
redeployed as home how long have you
been living here uh three or three three
weeks how do you feel about it so first
we will hear something blow up we're
around here but now we're like what was
that oh shooting
the experience is a trial for a new
mother called natalia
she gave birth to her son two days after
the invasion began
the hospital then sent her here
um
[Music]
they now live in the final car on
platform 2 with a cot and clothes
provided by volunteers
natalia says life
residents who remain will try to endure
but some are no longer able
the city morgue receives 50 to 100
bodies a day caused by the war and by
natural causes but they don't have room
to examine them here and they don't have
the staff to bury them
the man in charge says it's a real
struggle
[Music]
when a russian missile struck this
institute the entire neighborhood was
damaged in the blast
85 year old stella
told us she hung on to the door frame in
the hope she'd survive what was it like
when
the bombing happened when the missile
hit
[Music]
one of her neighbors called diana was
not so fortunate
she was caught in the explosion glass
from the windows puncturing her face
her doctor at harkev's
next door we found four men fighting for
their lives
one hit by shrapnel another blown up by
a mine
sergey is an opera singer turned
volunteer who was shot seven times as he
tried to evacuate local residents
and he celebrated with an old italian
song of resistance
[Music]
death and displacement have come to
everybody's doorstep but there are many
here who are determined to hold on
john sparks sky news harkev